est ce que vous avez dans une vidéo vous
incarniez johnny près d'une voiture en
faisant des gestes oui toi c'est bien
ouais bah isabelle pas vous n'avez qu'à
donner
merci isabelle vient gâcher une séquence
alors on va vérifier qu avec les indices
1 parce que voilà on regarde les trois
indices d'un coup donc il y avait il y
avait quoi comme un dj génial il est
bien sûr
une cadillac je les y avait impossible
la bagarre c'est une bonne réponse
isabelle bravo
je
yak jeu ni cadillac était avec nous dans
vidéo gag on va donc revenir sur cette
vidéo qui est mythique on l'a tous vu
plein de fois en 2014 johnny vous étiez
poser sur votre cadillac et vous gagnez
des conseils pour vous bagarrer on
regarde cette vidéo moi personnellement
je ne m'en lasse pas on regarde si ces
situations qu'a fait que qui a deux gars
qui sont en pointe dans un bistrot bâton
rôle c'est de les séparer messieurs
calmez vous il tombait mal parce que
c'est vrai que je sois même défendre ben
t'en veux aussi c'était le mot qu'il
fallait pas dire et alors l'heure le
couple le plus rapide du monde c'est
long week-end
mon nom mais au clou il est comme ça et
son tarif est de l'est et qui le choque
plat et à partir du moment il est chopé
là il voit plus clair partir on y voit
plus clair nous attendions m plat sa
gueule y'a pas de soucis mais bon ça
c'est ce que je faisais quand j'étais
jeune
maintenant je suis vieux maintenant
j'ai regardé si les trois fois comme moi
ben je vais plutôt plongé en dessous de
ces gens votre séjour b g liberté
couilles que j'ai fait
cette vidéo était sorti en 2014 c'est
absolument énorme johnny comment vous
est venue l'idée de faire cette vidéo
les deux nations c'est johnny la baston
c'est ça non c'est en fait c'est 8 qui
était venu faire une vera reportage
c'est au moins à l'époque et il ya
quelqu'un d'autre qui a repris les uns
une partie de l'émission et qui a sorti
ça et camille combal est tombé dessus
ouais et alors il a passé un thé pmp
donc chez cvs mais ça ça sent on a
l'impression que c'est off non c'est en
intensité en off ça devait pas être
diffusé ou on saluait diffuser
l'émission a été diffusée une émission
qui faisait lui donc c'était en fait il
avait cette vidéo mais vous voulez pas
forcément devenir connu et c'est ça moi
spécialement est en fait elle est passée
dans la chronique de camille combal
c'est vrai que ça a cartonné à la
reprise 4 millions du sang je suis à 11
millions bernard 11 millions alors
dites-moi est-ce que vous allez
rencontrer johnny ou pas oui mais en
1965 vrai qu'on m'a donné qu'on est
intéressant on adore johnny nous oui bah
moi aussi ça a changé votre vie oui oui
mais quand on commet à 65 il est comme
je sais bien mais qu'est ce qui s'est
passé à 65 en fait j'étais à la marine
marchande et sur le bateau bas j'avais
car c'est là peut-être du bosqueau le
métro dit
qu'il n'était pas content il s'est
plaint au capitaine commandant du port
quand je suis revenu à anvers alors
johnny cadillac vous êtes donc sosie
physique un de devenir loi est ce que
vous êtes sosie vocal aussi pas sosie
vocal mais j'ai hâte et poète et johnny
à ma façon donc j'étais un peu commun
vous chantez un peu je chante je veux
avant une petite démo
on a tous quelque chose en nous de
tennessee
quoi cette volonté de prolonger la nuit
ce désir fou de vivre une autre vie se
rêve en nous avec ses mots à lui oui
quelque chose de tennessee
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
super très très beau mais les points que
vous gagnez 10 grâce au fait vous soyez
associé à la fois vos points je suis
pété d'accord ok mais donc
je fais des petits concerts fin et des
gros quelquefois une de mes plus gros
seins nus et 1200 personnes donc c'était
quand même pendant l'arrêt quand même et
voilà je fais plus sa part hobby
d'accord que pour en poupe pour gagner
mais ce n'était pas votre activité
principale non non je suis retraité et
ça c'est mon activité mari qui a une
énorme concurrence entre les sosies de
johnny et non c'est vrai oui vous vous
pétez entre vous c'est
il y en a avec lesquels on est on est
très pop il y en a d'autres qui se la
pète un peu trop et je suis là où les
mettre la grosse tête donc il ya des
grosses têtes web alors avec bouvard à
johnny vous savez en ce moment dans un
chroniqueur qui est très à cran et qui a
vraiment envie d'en découdre sur l'eau
ni coeur c'est gilles verdez attendant
j'ai dit non mais c'est vrai il il a un
problème en ce moment c'est que dès
qu'on s'approche de sa compagne qui
s'appelle fatou ah oui devient très
agressif au président balawi mais
pourquoi voter là si vous arrivez lugano
mais c'est vrai ou pas absolument et à 2
alors pendant tout
[Applaudissements]
ce qu'il a dit
on va faire une petite mise en situation
s'il vous plaît
johnny va on va imaginer que c'est
quelqu'un qui veut draguer fatou ouais
donc toi tu va vouloir en venir aux
mains avec lui et jeudi qui est
inspectrice de la page
est aveugle il a dit tu vas devoir gym
et je n'ai pas dit répète à temps
johnny vous allez devoir neutraliser
j'aime beaucoup jean lève toi bien des
maux actuels neutraliser c'est ce qu'on
va voir à l'élève soit bien et donc
johnny belle essayé de draguer pas
toujours à ce qui se passe mais
j'ai évidemment qui ça dans la bouenza
transon c'est une leçon de sa rivière ce
qu'il a dit alors les agents de la
chanson répète h enfants
et tu savais quoi vous le bien
est ce qui vient me chercher
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il était parti
préfète la chanson j'ai
c'est ça qu'on appelle un faux cul comme
jean tu aimes vraiment toi le faux cul
oui mais celle que bientôt nous pas
merci sa mère si pour cette votation
si vous faites par en tout cas pas fait
peur tu fais peur et tes yeux là ouais
ouais il fait très peu de vent c'est
d'une tristesse absolue
heureusement que inscrits pour plastic
ans que sinon ils se bagarrent
attachante et à chansons peuvent alors
je sais pas chanter si elle veut arrêter
il aime mais voilà
alors johnny après cette vidéo donc on
va dire vous êtes devenu une star on
vous a vu dans pleins démission il ya
même des rappeurs je crois qu'ils vous
ont invité pour tourner dans leur clip
c'était un rappeur ukrainien regarder le
craignent un ouais
j'en entends gueule comme johnny
cadillac
dans ta gueule comme johnny cadillac à
nantes à gueule comme john cadillac
j'suis sûr mag cadillac match kadia
comme jaws khadiga au je suis pas bon en
bas le gardien mais tu ferais mieux de
pas le vérifier
un regard de huracan trois
[Applaudissements]
magnifiques
johnny cadillac et donc avec nous et que
moi je vois bien une gueule d'acteur
c'est vrai qu'il a au niveau des paroles
c'est j'ai tourné dans ce que bernard
bernard était très proche de johnny vous
êtes convaincu oui très convaincu par
les paroles de la chanson magnifique ok
c'est alors la retenir marques noms mais
les camps la limitation de johnny des
mutations père oui lui il est formidable
et très bon formidable ah bon alors je
vous rappelle qu'on joue avec
isabelle vergne a trouvé le nom de
johnny cadillac isabelle vous avez donc
attribuer un gars je vais piocher tout
de suite
la bulle vous avez
alors je voudrais donner le gage d'abord
révélé votre à c'est pas mal révélez
votre numéro de téléphone isabelle ou
celui d'un autre chroniqueur on va
révéler comme ce votre chouchou sam a
prodigieusement agacé m je vous en avais
parlé qu'à lui jean michel mr assez bien
très bonne idée et afin de révéler son
numéro 5 est enfin oui mais je vais
révéler le tir parce que je peux relever
issu d'un autre chroniqueur allez je
donne jamais mais non c'est toi non ah
oui si tu y
vas chroniqueur choisi vas-y vas-y mais
puisque la brume emmerder vasella
bah oui il faut que je rallume
malheureusement un
nom comme celui des suisses jean michel
six lancements
[Applaudissements]
pour contacter jean michel hiriart du
sac je te tiens par les couches annoncé
sur aucun dossier sur moi je vais vous
donner les premiers chiffres 07 78 37 06
ah bah voilà rivaux bah oui oui on
connaît il s est dominée chez vous ne
pas les deux derniers